clearstream on l'avait presque oublié
cette affaire clearstream celle révélée
par le journaliste denis robert en 2001
dans son livre révélation l'enquète son
adaptation sur grand écran réalisé par
vincent garenq nous replonge dans cette
affaire symptomatique de l'argent roi ou
la dissimulation de capitaux le
blanchiment d'argent la corruption sont
facilitées et encouragé par un système
de coopérative bancaire basé au
luxembourg est appelée clearstream le
scandale financier trouvera son
apothéose lorsque deux hommes politiques
français de premier plan y verront leurs
noms associés ce qui m'intéressait moi
c'est ce personnage de denis robert et
son enquête parce que j'avais
l'impression qu'avec sarkozy de villepin
ce qu'on nous avait raconté on n'avait
plus de sens et que le grand public
l'avait vraiment pas du tout compris
cette histoire l'enquète c'est aussi
l'histoire d'un homme le journaliste
denis robert incarné par gilles
lellouche ces révélations ne furent pas
sans conséquence pour sa vie privée
soixante trois procédures et 400 visites
d'huissiers furent le prix à payer de sa
liberté d'expression c'était un lanceur
d alerte l'air de rien il a et c'est
cette thématique des lanceurs d alerte
ça revient beaucoup mais on a besoin de
gens comme ça mais ces gens là où encore
aujourd'hui se prennent des procès
lorsqu'il a sorti le son premier livre
révélation toute la campagne promo a été
annulé
en l'espace de 48 heures donc évidemment
tous ses collègues journalistes
remettait en cause la véracité de ses
dires de son enquête même le bien fondé
de ce pourquoi il faisait tous ça
vincent garenq et gilles lellouche
réussissent la prouesse de faire de
clearstream un thriller grand public et
passionnant une prouesse pour l'un des
scandales les plus complexes de la vème
république